I think people who are in movies have a
responsibility to set a good example we
don't always do it but some do I think
our next presenter is a good example of
a good example Cicely Tyson
the Irving G Thalberg award is given by
special vote of the Academy Board of
Governors and not necessarily each year
it is by tradition the most special of
special Academy Awards and goes to a
creative producer whose body of work
reflects the consistently high quality
of production tonight's recipient is the
21st to be so honored some of his
predecessors are Samuel Goldwyn Darryl F
zanuck Cecil B DeMille David O Selznick
Walt Disney Ingmar Bergman and last
year's winner Mervyn Leroy Irving
Thalberg was the ultimate producer and
the Boy Wonder
it took tonight's recipient more than
eight years working his way up the
ladder before he won his producer
stripes it is a tribute to on-the-job
training that he ultimately moved from
second assistant director and assistant
film editor to become one of our most
distinguished producers in three decades
he gave us more than 75 films stunning
in their variety top-hat the gay
divorcee Stage Door Alice Adams Ivanhoe
National Velvet
of Human Bondage The Hunchback of Notre
Dame the Blackboard Jungle Butterfield 8
room service and Gunga Din enormous ly
popular pictures was beloved star ladies
and gentlemen
here is the recipient of the 21st
curving G Thalberg award pand row s
Burman
I gratitude to the many wonderful men
and women who are my co-workers through
the years some of my films have
attempted to reflect the times others
were works of pure fantasy the marvelous
thing about this medium is that I could
present my dreams as well as my feelings
I had nothing to lose so I played my
hunches a standard complaint of
producers over the years has been that
the studio ruined the picture or got me
to change it or the ads were lousy or
the distributor didn't understand the
film in my case this wasn't so the
pictures that went out with my name good
bad or indifferent were produced by me
and when I knew what I wanted and when I
wanted it badly enough I got it on the
screen my thanks to the Academy for not
being indifferent and for forgetting the
bad and remembering the good
you